hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in book three of his poem on the nature
of things after he has explained to us
how the mind and spirit interconnected
with each other and interconnect with
the body are actually material composed
of very very fine atoms lucretius is
going to ask well what kind of atoms is
it actually
made of and we're probably not going to
accept the physics that is underlying
the distinctions that he's going to make
and the explanations that he's going to
provide but we can follow along and see
what it is that he's saying and
determine whether we think that there's
anything to something analogous to this
and so he begins
by telling us it must not be supposed
the stuff of mind or spirit
is a single element simplex natura
so they're not just like mind stuff or
something like that we can
formulate what they are in terms of
other kinds of
things
elements as we can call them
and the choice of elements here is going
to be a little bit unfamiliar to people
who are used to thinking about you know
the greeks had four elements earth air
fire water and then maybe a fifth
element the quintessence you know that
was attributed to aristotle that could
be the the subject of mind or something
like that so lucretius is actually going
to single out some
other types of elements
that we can see you know in other things
besides the human being
so he tells us the body at death this is
what what is lacking is abandoned
by a sort of rarefied wind and the first
term that he uses for that is aura which
can mean wind or breeze or something
like that a movement of the air and then
he uses the term ventus which also means
wind as well and this may strike us as a
bit weird to think of the wind itself as
being an element particularly since he's
going to contrast it against another
element air itself what's the difference
between wind and air you just kind of
have to go with him
on this
you could call them element one element
two element three if you like if that
helps you out so we have wind right
and then the wind is mixed with
warmth vapor literally the word we get
vapor from so like steam
or
you could use this of incense or
something like that as well
and but he also is going to talk about
heat kalor and he's going to use that a
bit more throughout his explanation so
now we've got two elements
wind which has heat and again forget
everything that you know about modern
physics try to put yourself in the
perspective of the epicureans at the
time
and then he goes on and he says well
warmth carries with it also
air
and the you know the latin for that is
just air
the word that we actually get air from
so we've got now three different
elements and he says that
indeed heat never occurs without air
being mixed with it because it is
naturally sparse it must have many atoms
of air moving in its interstices what
are interstices little
holes little gaps in which other things
can
go in right if we think about the fabric
for example that my shirt and tie are
made of they look very solid but if we
looked at it very closely we'd see all
sorts of little gaps right and that's in
a
fabric that's tied together that's at a
macro level compared to these elements
so these elements
interpenetrate each other not that the
atoms themselves interpenetrate but the
we could call them larger composites of
the atoms have lots and lots of
possibility for for
inter you know uh interacting with each
other for flowing into each other
through these interstices so now we've
got these these three different elements
and he goes on and he says
so the composition of mind
is thus far found to be at least
threefold
three different things working together
in the mind in the spirit and then he
says these three components together
are not enough to create sentience the
capacity to sense things right the mind
does not admit that any of these can
create the sensory motions that
originate the meditations revolved in
the mind we see that there's air we see
that there's wind we see that there's
heat outside of ourselves and those
things don't produce
you know like a fire by itself is not
sentient i mean we could say well you
know if it feels its way to where the
wood is no no lucretius doesn't buy into
that
so he says we have to add to these a
fourth component which is quite nameless
then there is then this there is nothing
more mobile or more tenuous so
wind heat and air are by themselves very
mobile and tenuous the entirety of our
mind and spirit are
that way as well but this
goes even further
in that way then he says this is what
first sets the sensory motions
coursing through the limbs owing to the
minuteness of its atoms it is first to
be stirred then the motions are then
there's like a chain here right so first
the fourth element is stirred for the
fourth element does things and then heat
catches on the atoms that are composing
heat that are intersecting with this
fourth element and its atoms are moved
and then what happens after that the
unseen energy of wind and then air and
then it gets into
our body itself and our bodies
atoms the much you know larger and
heavier
and harder to be moved things that you
know he says bones and marrow
are thrilled with the pleasure or the
opposite excitement right
and so you know what we've got here is
kind of an interesting account for
how it is that our our minds and our
vital spirit throughout our body
interconnected with each other
how they actually are brought into
motion how it is that we can have
thoughts about things
and he tells us that these atoms of
these elements they intersect with each
other there's a beautiful line
uh here where he says the atoms rush in
and out amongst one another on atomic
trajectories so that none no one of them
can be segregated nor its distinctive
power isolated by intervening space they
coexist
like the many properties of a single
body here he's giving us an analogy
so what do we know about a
body that's observable because remember
i mean the fourth element totally
unobservable right these other elements
not really observable
by say the naked eye right but he's
saying that these are here
so you know in the flesh of any living
thing he says
there are regularly scent and color and
taste so sensible properties right
and yet from all of these there's formed
only one corporeal
bulk it's not as if you first have the
scent and then the
color
and then the
taste and you just like glom them all
together as if we're doing computer
programs or something like that and boom
you've got a substance
no they they are there all together
so he's saying that these actually form
a single substance within us that we
call the the mind or intellect and the
the
vital spirit unum
so it's not he's not saying substance
but you know close enough
to that
and he goes on and he says
just so warmth and air and the unseen
energy of wind
create in combination a single substance
together with that mobile force which
imparts to them the initial impetus from
which the sensory motion takes its rise
throughout the flesh so all four of
these are working together this basic
substance he says lurks at our very
core
there's nothing in our bodies more
fundamental than this the most vital
element of the whole
vital spirit so this is
this is what our minds and our spirit
actually are and they then go into and
penetrate and you know essentially use
the rest of the body that they're
connected with so it says in the same
way wind and air and warmth commingled
through the limbs must interact
one being relatively latent another
prominent in appearance a single stuff
is formed by them all
warmth and wind and air do not display
their powers separately to blot out
sentience and dissolve it by their own
union or disunion and then he's going to
say
interestingly you get different things
from these different elements
he doesn't tell us about the fourth
element in this way because it's we
already know what it's bringing
sentience the capacity to think that
sort of thing but each of these has you
could say emotions or attitudes
associated with it which are reflections
of the
relative importance or agency of of each
of these so he begins with talking about
heat
it brings this element into play when it
boils with rage and passion blazes more
fiercely from the eyes so when we're
being very active when we're being
perhaps competitive when we're angry
when we're seeking revenge when we're
responding to threats when we get angry
in general that is this element of heat
that is coming to the fore the opposite
of this to some degree
he's he says there's no
lack
of that chill wind companion of fright
fear which sets the limbs a tremble and
impels them to flight and then lastly
there's that calm and steady air which
prevails in a tranquil blood breast and
unruffled countenance so we've
essentially got three different kinds of
temperaments here or
things that that produce emotions within
us uh anger and activity
fear and you know flightfulness and then
finally a solidity or
sanguine aspect as well associated with
air
and he gives us some examples of animals
having uh determinate characteristics
for their species based on this now he
tells us something kind of kind of crazy
about lions i'm not sure where he's
getting this from in those creatures
whose passionate hearts and angry
dispositions easily boil up in anger
there is a surplus of the hot element
and he says lions roar until they burst
their chests with bellowing and cannot
keep the torrents of their rage pen
within their hearts if this is
understood metaphorically like you know
the lion's roar is just so so aggressive
and scary great if he thinks that they
actually like burst open their chests ah
you know you gotta wonder
where the
observation of animal behavior is coming
in here and then he talks about deer
he says the cold hearts of deer are of a
windier blend they are quicker to set
chill breezes flowing through the flesh
provoking a shuddering movement in their
limbs right so they they very easily
feel
fear or anxiety or panic or something
like that because of the wind element
predominating and then he talks about
cattle
cattle have a bigger portion of calm air
they're never too hotly fired by the
torch of anger they're never transfixed
and benumbed by the icy shaft of fear
their nature he says is a mean between
the timidity of the deer and the lions
ferocity so this suggests that maybe
there's like a continuum going on here
but we could also think of this as like
a
being out of that spectrum and doing its
own thing as well now what about us
human beings
we have
different compositions within our souls
he says though education or teaching
literally people can be educated it can
apply a similar polish to various
individuals it can like try to give them
the same characteristics
he says it still leaves fundamental
traces um vestigia right is or vestigiai
in in the plural is the
word
you know when we say that something is
vested vestigial there is like a little
bit of it left over or like an
aftertaste you could say right and these
are of our original compositions of our
souls and our minds so he says
it must not be supposed that innate
vices can be completely eradicated one
person will still incline
too readily to outbursts of rage another
will give way to fear too soon a third
will accept some contingencies too
passively each of these is associated
with an element predominating within our
soul and so he says
men must differ from one another in
temperament and also in the resultant
behavior so he's providing here an
explanation for
human
comportment human
uh attitudes and things like that he
says i'm not gonna try to explain that
that's beyond my power i don't even have
a names for the multiplicity of atomic
shapes that give rise to this variety of
types but i am clear there is one
relevant fact i can affirm the lingering
traces of inborn temperament
that cannot be eliminated by philosophy
or so slight there's nothing to prevent
people from living a life equal to the
god so he he is actually saying as
opposed to the other animals that are
kind of stuck with the souls that they
have or the the spirits that they have
by education we can actually modify
our composition
of elements or how they're working
together within the human mind and it's
kind of hinted here that maybe that
fourth element
plays a role in that but he doesn't he
doesn't go on to explain it but you know
where else is the educator and educated
what's going to be going on in there
it's probably going to be a matter of
this this fourth element of sentience
and
reflexivity you could say so this is uh
how lucretius thinks the mind and the
spirit the animals and anima are
actually composed of
material elements which then
play a very significant role
in
leading to different attitudes and
behavior
you